Train constantly.
My Foster Snyder,
ah, got to repay. It Burns
the triad is make me smarter.
I train my models in the cloud now
because my laptop takes longer.
I parse through data like
a boss now back then,
mock code was wronger subscribe
if you want to learn now,
let's spread this AI power
pretty there right now.
Great.
Let's make pots to nine and make music
like Mozart tonight and pay artwork on a
cross tonight.
I'm waiting for this software all my life.
Just give it some data and
watch it. Explore a step
back. Clap and give an encore.
She is trained on 40 cores.
Does race or make GP use anymore?
My game but started off [inaudible] list,
but now it's like God in the Matrix.
It's my chat Bot speaks. Once I train
it, I worked damn hard to make page.
It'll generate words that he appreciates.
Analyze sits a bit that tested.
This is the shit to invest in.
New Data was there training and tested.
Got to read papers to
try and make me smarter.
I train my models in the cloud now
because my laptop takes longer.
I'll parse through data like a bottle.
Now. Back then, my code was stronger.
Subscribe if you want to learn now,
let's spread this AI power.
You're right.